I've heard that they are withholding
their technologies until we behave
better if you stop dropping bombs on
each other then we'll give you something
to replace fossil fuels and we're just
like nah boom an alien is a creature
from somewhere in outer space
I don't know exactly where I have no
details on that they could be people Lee
but I think it's probably gonna be more
like plant me I think they have the
ability to maybe mimic us and like
reflect us there are documented species
of aliens I've got the gray alien the
short gray is the tall greys the mantis
people which are really cool maybe some
aliens just yes I think they're here
already I mean I think there's a lot of
evidence that they are there's thousands
of accounts and a lot of them are from
retired military officials I think
they've at least been here like oh who
could have made the pyramids and I'm not
necessarily suggestions the pyramids
there was a crash there was some dead
bodies and one I think there was like
one or two allow you in the community
there's this cool thing that says that
Eisenhower went to Roswell and talked to
the aliens and made like a treaty with
the grey aliens saying that we'll give
you all of this technology and you give
us people to abduct for a while
consensual to many stories have been put
out there of like aliens doing like but
stuff to people you know what I mean
yeah I don't know my door I'll have a
cup of tea with me Oh chat to you and
then you'll leave I don't think I need
to be abducted this year I would be
totally down I'd say let's let's make a
kid right now I want to see what it
looks like we'd probably end up being in
a bit of a love bubble because no one
else would know about them they look
like humans Oh
as imagine them as a little like alien
Portman oh I wasn't I was imagining
there was a sexy man Oh a sexy man I
could fall in love with an alien like I
don't know you like spoon anything if I
was an alien I don't think I would try
to cause chaos I'd be an evil alien IV
yeah I wouldn't blend in and save
everyone I really like these planets I
wouldn't want to destroy it it's my
favorite favorite why not they can teach
us how to teleport and we can teach you
them how to like make mozzarella please
please we had a teleport I actually feel
like we're more dangerous than them
because we can't control ourselves very
well I think just knowing that this more
people out there besides us is more
comforting to me than to know that we're
the only things alive in the whole
universe if we're a thing they have to
be a thing it's yeah the universe is too
big for them to not be a thing the idea
that we're alone and that we're the only
example of something that you could
define as life I think is absolutely
tuned into Roswell New Mexico new series
Tuesday 9/8 central on the CW
[Music]